this morning tara string fellow and
memphis her debut novel it's a
multi-generational story about family
heartbreak and moving forward
stringfellow changed her entire life to
throw herself into this book
what she's produced is both a tribute to
her ancestors
and to a city she adores
[Music]
[Applause]
memphis in may reminded him of cool
ridge's ode to xanadu stately pleasure
domes were massive plantation houses
with wraparound porches on every tier
and the majesty of the mississippi river
could put to shame any sacredness of the
elf
[Music]
you've lived all over the world but you
keep coming back here yes
yes i mean it's gorgeous
why live anywhere else in the world tara
stringfellow grew up on a military base
in japan
and has lived in ghana
cuba
spain and italy
but it was in memphis where her family's
been rooted for generations that she
wrote her first novel
while working as a 10th grade teacher it
was the most beautiful moment of my life
to share the book deal with my students
so they could see in in a classroom full
of black students so they could see that
you know the love
or the love of english
right like i was literally teaching them
how to love reading i said it will pay
off
promise it will pay off and then to
actually
experience that with them like wow
this is the writing room this is it
this is my girl
memphis unfolds over the course of 70
years before and after race and poverty
thrust this city to the forefront of the
civil rights movement
it features three generations of black
women all steeped in stringfellow's
personal history
at the top is hazel the matriarch and
her husband myron the first black police
detective in memphis
just like stringfellow's real-life
grandfather
she calls this book the monuments he
never got
also hazel and myron's daughters miriam
in august and their grandchildren
including joan who finds solace in
painting are you joan are you miriam are
you my i was i would say joan right
no i feel like i'm all of them okay
those parts were easy for me to write
her obsessiveness but in some ways i'm
maya you know i
i try and be funny it's very rare it
happens only occasionally i'm the most
inopportune of times but sometimes i'm
funny and you know i speak italian parlo
italiano studiato italiano
and italia so you know i
you know writing those parts where she
was speaking italian was just fun for me
i was like yes i get to write my second
language basically and then
sometimes you know i want to be alone in
my kimono with my cigarette in my house
so sometimes i'm auntie august you know
i feel like
i'm all of the women i also went through
my own divorce
and started over you completely changed
your life upended
everything i did
because you couldn't live that way
not a second longer
stringfellow who in her past life was a
married lawyer
was raised around poetry which she says
is still her one true love you wrote
your first poem ever
to your
dad and you say your last poem ever
will probably be for him too
my first poem my last poem i just you
know he taught me poetry he's a poet
and he instilled in me a love of
literature of prose a verse of haiku of
elizabethan sonnet iambic pentameter he
taught he taught it all to me at a very
young age so he sounds awesome
a marine poet can you believe it the
only reason he's not here is he's at the
pentagon right now working for you is he
more marine or more poet
he's he's my pops
he is my favorite person on this earth
stringfellow never has to look far for
inspiration
that includes a second edition copy of f
scott fitzgerald's the great gatsby a
gift from her mother
parts of which she's memorized gatsby
saw that the blox's sidewalk really
formed a ladder that mounted to an
invisible point somewhere beyond the
trees he could climb to it if he climbed
alone and once there he could suck on
the path of life gulp down the
incomparable milk of wonder
i'd do it you did it
his heartbeat faster and faster as
daisy's white face came up to his own
daisy buchanan he knew that when he
kissed this girl
and forever wed his unutterable visions
to her perishable breath
his mind would never romp again like the
mind of god um
drop again like the mind of god get
after it buddy i i do have to say
fitzgerald could write he could write a
sentence or two you are dying he could
write a sentence or two
[Music]
for a string fellow these days
nothing makes her heartbeat faster
or with more satisfaction than getting
to be here
in memphis every day
telling stories
i can't imagine a world in which i
hadn't made the move
i just can't imagine a world in which i
was tara m stringfellow esquire
and not poet
i don't think my family would be happy
for me honestly you wouldn't be happy i
wouldn't be happy
but now you are
yes
yes
she's joyous she is so happy yes i asked
her whether she'd rather be writing or
sitting out on the porch talking to
neighbor what she does every night with
huckleberry she said can i have my
poetry notepad with me at the same time
on the porch
um so yeah she's doing great and she's
just i mean she changed her life to do
this she got after it buddy yeah she got
after it
something from you i've never seen
before she got after us
that was awesome it was
great piece